ça c'est vous vous êtes l'un des 1500
enfants qui vont naître aujourd'hui dans
cette ruche ce que vous ne saviez pas
encore c'est qu'un événement allait
changer votre destin ça fait 20 jours
que votre mère va mal la reine des
abeilles vieilli elle nous pour plus à
ses deux héros du moins de phéromones ça
provoque un véritable vent de panique
chez les ouvrières il faut absolument
trouver une remplaçante
on pourrait penser que c'est la reine
qui choisit la descendance royale en
pondant à neuf spéciales par exemple
mais non ce sont les ouvrières qui vont
choisir leur future maîtresse elles vont
sélectionner plusieurs au hasard et leur
donner un traitement de faveur
l'un de ces oeufs c'est vous pourquoi
avoir été choisi la science ne le sait
pas parce que les abeilles ont perçu en
vous le meilleur potentiel génétique
le fait est que au lieu de devenir
ouvrière comme tout le monde vous allez
devenir reine vous et les quatre autres
abeilles à côté de vous car oui vous
n'êtes pas seuls à prétendre au trône et
quelque chose me dit que ça va mal finir
pour l'instant les ouvrières vous
chouchoute elles ont construit autour de
vous un gros cocon de cire une cellule
royal probablement pour vous donner plus
de place et vous protéger du chaos qui
règne dans la ruche la reine est en
mourante les ouvrières devenues folles
vont aussi se mettre à pondre sachez le
les ouvrières ne sont pas stériles
la différence c'est qu'elles ne peuvent
pondre que des mâles j'imagine que vous
n'avez jamais vu d'abeilles mal et c'est
normal leur destin sera tragique on les
appelle faux bourdons il ne faut pas de
miel ils n'ont pas d'art et leur seule
utilité avant de mourir s'accoupler avec
vous la future n là encore quelque chose
me dit que ça va mal finir votre
transformation en reine des abeilles va
se faire en seulement seize jours le
secret c'est juste votre alimentation
qui va différer des larves basique
voyez cette espèce de miel blangy latine
ec2 la gelée royale une sorte de miel un
peu spéciale appelée des abeilles
produite par les couveuses normalement
une abeille reçoit de la gelée royale
pendant trois jours pour les futures
reines ça sera toute leur vie et ça va
faire la différence
en effet en plus d'être beaucoup plus
nutritifs plus gras plus sucré plus
vitaminées et il contient une protéine
très spécial
la roya lakhtine
une substance qui va agir directement
sur vos gènes elle va vous rendre
beaucoup plus grosses et plus aptes à la
reproduction avec par exemple une
spermathèque dans votre abdomen pour
conserver la semence plein d'autres
parties de votre corps vont aussi être
impactées par la gelée royale
vous n'aurez pas d'organe de succion
vous rendant incapable de vous nourrir
seul ce sera à vos sujets de vous donner
la becquée votre d'art sera aussi
différent au lieu d'être barbelés il est
lisse ce qui fait que vous pouvez piquer
plusieurs fois comme une guêpe la houle
ouvrière perdra son abdomen avant de
périr dernier avantage et non des
moindres en tant qu rennes votre
espérance de vie sera décuplée si tout
se passe bien vous vivrez jusqu'à cinq
ans ce qui vous laissera le temps de
voir des centaines de milliers de vos
enfants mourir devenir reine des
abeilles est très violent jour 16
il est en faveur de sortir de votre
cellule royal et de prendre vos
fonctions de rennes vous devrez
néanmoins prouver que vous êtes à la
hauteur
les ouvrières ne vous connaissent pas
encore car vous ne produisez pas assez
de phéromones mais ce n'est pas le plus
important
côté de votre cocon d'autres alvéoles
bouche de façon inquiétante
ce sont vos soeurs elles aussi nourri à
la gelée royale et elles vont bientôt
n'être vous le savez malheureusement
personne n'a jamais vu plusieurs reines
sur le trône il ne peut en exister
qu'une vous décidez alors de prendre une
grande inspiration dû pousser votre cri
le plus terrifiant
c'en sera qu'une note un sol dièse un
sol dièse qui annoncera le grand
massacre fratricides à venir
ce que vous entendez c'est le chant des
reines il a deux fonctions déjà prévenir
la ruche que vous avez officiellement
pris la place de rain et surtout annoncé
à vos concurrentes qui doit falloir se
battre à ce chant vos soeurs vont elles
aussi libre et si le chant est faible
c'est qu'elles sont encore bébé alors
vous transpercer leurs cellules royales
de votre d'art l'inondant leur petit
corps de votre poison vous la sortez de
son berceau et nous massacrent vous
commencez par contre si le chant et
puissance et que vos soeurs sont tout
aussi fortes que vous vous avez alors
deux choix
le premier la fuite vous quittez la
ruche avec la moitié de la colonie pour
en fonder une nouvelle on appelle cet
envol l'essaimage
mais c'est possible uniquement si la
température extérieure est chaude dans
tous les autres cas il va falloir vous
battre votre soeur la plus musclée sorti
de son cocon et elle s'approche vers
vous
toute la ruche vous regarde vous le
savez ça sera sans pitié
elle vous foncent dessus vous tombé au
fond de la rue ça dure plusieurs minutes
vous pensiez n'avoir aucune chance mais
enfin vous voyez une faille dans sa
défense voulu planter votre d'art dans
l'abdomen elle hurle de douleur
désolé serais tu il n'y a qu'une place
pour être red bull a poignardé à nouveau
lui injectant votre venin mortel sa vie
n'aura duré que quelques minutes
loin de vous juger la ruche applaudi les
ouvrières sont contentes une nouvelle
reine peut régner il ne faut pas tomber
amoureux de la reine des abeilles
voilà c'était la dernière prétendante
vous êtes désormais la seule reine
cependant vous n'avez pas encore de
pouvoir sur la colonie pour cela il
faudra augmenter la puissance de vos
phéromones puisqu'une rennes ne dirige
pas que par la voix elle manipule
l'esprit de ces sujets grâce à ces
odeurs le problème ici c'est que vous
êtes vierge et que vous sentez la vierge
or les ouvrières ne pourront pas
respecter une petite puce être comme
vous heureusement avant votre naissance
elles ont pondu des mâles les faubourgs
dont ils vont bien s'occuper de vous
parce que ici pas de bisou pour la
princesse on n'est pas dans un disney ça
sera violent venais à peine de naître et
vous devez déjà passés à la casserole
je crois que
au bout de quelques jours vous allez
devoir faire votre vol nuptial peut-être
la seule sortie de la ruche que vous
allez faire de toute votre vie
le but sera de rencontrer un maximum de
mal pour remplir votre spermathèque de
la semence que vous allez devoir stocker
et utiliser tout au long de votre vie je
vous rassure vous n'allez pas vous à
coupler avec les mâles de votre propre
ruche les abeilles ont beau être
monstrueuse elles ne sont pas pour
autant incestueuse votre matériel
génétique vous pourrez le trouver ainsi
dans les rues environnantes
en tant que jeune reine votre vol est
rapide très rapide
seuls les faubourgs dont les plus
performants pour vous rattraper et
s'accoupler avec vous et c'est pas une
chance une fois sa petite affaire
terminée ils se séparent violemment vous
ce qui entraîne l'ablation de ses
organes génitaux
ouais ils se coupent la zigounette
désolé garçons ici c'est comme cinder
n'y aura pas de second rendez vous
fatalement pour lui ça sera une longue
agonie douloureuse mais pour ceux qui
n'ont pas réussi à s'accoupler
c'est pas mieux pas question de
retourner à la ruche leur destin sera
terrait dans la nature ça sera pas un
beau voyage en solo car d'ici la fin de
la journée seront dévorer vivants par un
oiseau difficile d'être un mal dans une
société de rennes et justement vous la
reine
là vous êtes bien vous avez rencontré
plein de beaux garçons vous avez discuté
bu un verre arracher leurs organes
génitaux et rempli votre ventre de
semences la routine quoi
cependant vous avez de la chance on
estime que 20 % et rennes ne reviennent
jamais problème de localisation gruchet
tout simplement dévorée par anne oiseaux
dans ce cas la ruche peut être condamné
c'est là que les apiculteurs
interviennent avec son appel le ring
ils introduisent dans la ruche une jeune
reine vierge qui vient d'une autre ruche
dans 90% des cas ça se passe bien
ne t'inquiète pas passé car la jeune
abbey n'a pas d'odeur particulière
contre une reine féconder seraient tués
sur le champ car elle s'en tire est
l'étrangère dans cette vidéo la jeune
reine dans sa cage de protection a été
rejetée par la colonie tout le monde
veut la tuer imaginez vous entoure et
d'inconnu derrière une grille qui
veulent vous des chiper est déversée en
vous un venin mortel qui a dit que la
nature est belle une
peut-elle survivre sans rennes
maintenant vous êtes féconder les
ouvrières vous obéissent lorsqu'elle
vous sentent une puissante envie de
travailler s'éveille en elle elles
veulent s'occuper de vous nourrir vos
larves faire du miel
vous allez être chouchoutée nourrit
toiletter les ouvrières s'occupe romaine
de vos excréments la seule activité
physique que vous aurez à faire c'est
prendre et pas qu'un peu puisqu'il
faudra tenir un rythme de 1500 à 2000
par jour et je vous conseille de tenir
la cadence car si vous veniez à pondre
tropez où aller trop stérile votre
colonie va décider de vous éliminer
vous allez aussi de voir réguler la
population de la ruche en fonction des
périodes selon les besoins vous pourrez
décider de mettre au monde des mâles ou
des femelles à votre guise et ça va être
important parce que lorsque l'hiver
arrive
la ruche va chercher à économiser les
ressources premier réflexe chasser les
mâles non seulement ils foutent rien ils
consomment des ressources mais en plus
ils ne peuvent même plus fécondes et les
femelles des autres ruches baril en
hiver il fait trop froid pour voler
allez zou man de trash
un autre cas qui peut demander des
mesures radicales c'est quand la ruche
et surpeuplé une colonie peut atteindre
60 mille individus mais il ya quand même
un chiffre maximum à partir duquel il
n'y a plus de place vous allez donc
devoir prendre une décision important
que vous ne prendrait qu'une seule fois
dans votre vie
l'essaimage dans un premier temps vous
allez baisser votre sécrétion de
phéromones pour que les ouvrières pense
que vous êtes en train de mourir ça
permet de les manipuler afin qu'elle
prépare de nouvelles cellules royales
pour vous remplacer
vous n'aurez ensuite qu'à réunir la
moitié de la colonie et quitter le nid à
la recherche d'un nouvel endroit pour
construire une nouvelle ruche c'est un
phénomène rare si vous en voyez ne
prenez surtout pas peur et estimez vous
même heureux la fin de votre règne cinq
années sont passées
c'est à votre tour de devenir faible la
spermathèque que vous aviez rempli lors
de votre vol nuptial est quasiment à sec
vous ne pondent est quasiment plus les
ouvrières le sentent et vous savez
maintenant ce qu'elles vont faire
vous les voyez là-bas choisir le futur
enfant qui vous remplacera vos enfants
qu'ils recommenceront ce cycle atroce de
violence la nature est belle
est-il lorsque la nouvelle reine naîtra
vous la verrez tuer vos filles ses
concurrentes ne la jugez pas vous aviez
fait pareil à son tour sous cri
terrifiant rugira dans toute la rue
c'est fait minette plus rennes la
nouvelle et belle athlétique puissante
elle s'approche de vous et pourra
choisir de cohabiter avec sa vieille
mère pour vos derniers moments enfin fin
c'est dans le meilleur des cas il ya de
grandes chances pour qu'elle décide
plutôt de vous exécutez ou de vous
abandonner hors de la ruche
la vieille femme que vous êtes là aucune
chance de survie voilà à quoi vous est
réduite
tout ça à cause de votre propre fille
c'est triste surtout que vous savez
qu'elle n'aura aucun remords maintenant
que vous me servait plus à rien adieu
reine des abeilles
[Musique]